you
I think probably I always have been a
scientist I don't think I've ever not
been a scientist so whether it's
something you're born with or whether
it's something you're fortunate enough
to have intelligent parents you can you
are clear the Nobel Prize YouTube
channel is an excellent distribution
platform video puts you in the scene it
allows you to see what's going on see
the action video gives you that sense of
being that other media can't do as well
leader has a directors it's fast it's
direct the drama of some of our years
Horace Hank are looking at all the
Swedish Academy announcing a new name on
laureate in literature my personal
favorite is an interview with the Nobel
laureate in literature for 2007 Doris
Lessing don't you think we should do
something about his teeth he was filmed
in Doris Lessing's flat in London and
get a real flavor for how she lives you
can really hear or see a bit of the
humour of the Nobel laureates tried to
squeeze into their banquet speeches
mommy mommy I won a prize that's
wonderful my dear now eat your carrots
before they get cold
all right now you can have your say
about the 2008 Nobel prizes in
literature or peace by posting a video
comment and we hope this encourages more
discussion about the Nobel prizes if you
want to get to know the Nobel laureates
we're able to do that in a way that
nobody else can
you